(soft music)
- I remember when you used to
be my little girl, you know.
- I'm not your little girl no more.
(soft music)
- [Man] Yo fam.
- What happened to your arm cuz?
- [Man] I had a stroke fam.
- A stroke?
That's an old man ting though, isn't it?
- Too many balloons bro.
- You were doing nos yeah?
- Put on a bit of weight.
Hair's going
- Fucking hell.
- Stress fam.
- Bruv, didn't I tell
you to fucking text me..
Yo, yo,
yo fam
Dris.
Are you all right?
- Course.
- Yesterday?
- Yeah I didn't take my meds.
It aint happened before,
it won't happen again.
Fuck!
You said that we were partners in this,
me, you and Sully.
- We are partners.
- This aint a partner level type job bro.
- Dris, I said I want you to go.
It needs to be you, go.
Fuck sake.
Dris, I need 10 bags, I
don't care how you get it.
- Bruv what the fuck's his problem?
- Shut your fucking mouth.
- Flash prick ya know.
Don't fucking let him
talk to you like that.
- Things are changing now you know.
- They're about to get heavy.
You know if I can't take
the heat out of this Jamie
situation they're only
going to get heavier init.
- Bruv why are you telling me this?
This aint nuttin we aint
been through before?
- I need someone I can rely on Dris.
- What?
- Bro you've been slipping fam.
Since I got back you've been slipping.
Bro the fits, the medication.
All the other fucking drugs.
Get yourself clean bruv.
You'll be back before you know it.
- Someone I know will pay a lot of money
for someone you know.
- Who do I know?
- Sully.
When you getting your p's and respect?
When?
Yeah.
How you gonna give Erin a
proper childhood she deserves
if you're always bottom of the pile bro?
- Who's that?
Fuck
(gunshot)
- Hey listen,
you know it weren't by chance,
that them man found us yesterday.
No fucking way.
- Bro it better not be
him that's all I'm saying.
- Wait hold on, so it was you?
Fam you know you fucked up init.
As soon as Dushane and Sully
find out about this bro
you're fucking done out here..
- Calm down, you know why I called you,
do you want it or not?
- Aye he's not here fam.
- Let's go, yo let's go man, let's move.
- [Group] What the fuck.
Where the fuck were they man?
What the fuck.
Bro where the fuck were they man?
Fucking shits bruv.
(shouting)
(door opening)
(sad violin music)
- Dris we can do it here but,
Erin's gonna find you.
- Can I put some shoes on?
- Why?
Why man?
- If you're gonna do it, do it fam.
(gunshot)